Вітаю! Мене звати пан Вадим.
Я вчитель хімії.
Сьогоднішня тема – кислоти.
Тож, давайте почнемо з того,
що ми вже знаємо з 8 класу
та отримаємо деякі нові знання
про такі хімічні речовини, як кислоти.
Ви вже пройшли два окремих класи сполук
– це були неорганічні кислоти у 8 класі,
та органічні кислоти у 9 і 10 класах.
Що об’єднувало ці
два різних класи сполук?
Їх об’єднував один і той же самий факт,
що при дисоціації вони генерували протон
або Аш з плюсом.
Давайте згадаємо, які формули
у кислот і що особливого було?
Неорганічні кислоти
поділялись на оксигенові,
тобто ті, де був присутній
атом оксигену та безоксигенові,
як не дивно, там не було атому оксигену
Також ви вже знайомі з
деякими органічними кислотами.
Власне, просто органічними кислотами,
тобто ті, в кого були карбоксильна група
а також амінокислоти –
це ті кислоти, в яких одночасно
була присутня і карбоксильна
і аміногрупа.
В будь-якому випадку, що в
неорганічних кислотах наш гідроген,
що в органічних
кислотах ось цей гідроген -
був здатний до дисоціації,
тобто генерувати Аш з плюсом.
Тепер в загальному випадку ми можемо
сказати, що кислоти – це ті речовини,
які при дисоціації здатні генерувати в
достатній кількості протон Аш з плюсом.
Загальний варіант
дисоціації запишемо на дошці.
Якщо будь-яку кислоту
записати загальною формулою
Аш-ен та якийсь кислотний
залишок – відповідний аніон,
то вона буде дисоціювати на деяку
кількість гідрогену і цей аніон,
відповідно з тим зарядом, скільки
у вас тут залишається гідрогенів.
Згадаємо трошки про назви кислот.
З неорганічної хімії ви
пам’ятаєте, що деякі кислоти
дуже часто називаються в
залежності від того елементу,
який утворює ці кислоти
або центральний елемент.
Якщо взяти безоксигенові
неорганічні кислоти, в
они називались в залежності від того
елементу, який утворював цю кислоту:
Аш-Хлор – хлоридна кислота
Аш-два-Ес – сульфідна кислота.
Прошу звернути увагу на суфікс.
Тут чергується один і той
же самий суфікс “ид” та ”ід”.
Якщо у вас елемент знаходиться
в найнижчому ступені окислення,
в даному випадку це мінус 1
для хлору та мінус 2 для сульфуру,
то для назви ви використовуєте
суфікс “ид” або ”ід”.
Якщо ж ви переходите до оксигеновмісних
кислот, ваш ступінь окислення змінюється.
Наведемо приклади.
Аш-два-Ес-О-чотири,
Аш-два-Ес-О-три, Аш-Ен-О-три
Дамо назви цим кислотам.
Аш-два-Ес-О-чотири – сульфатна кислота,
Аш-два-Ес-О-три – сульфітна кислота,
Аш-Ен-О-три – нітратна кислота.
Для виявлення деякої закономірності
замалюємо ще одну кислоту
Аш-Ен-О-два – нітритна кислота.
Подивіться уважно на суфікси.
В перших випадках, коли сульфур
був у вищій ступені окислення
і нітроген був у вищій ступені
окислення: +6 і +5 відповідно,
суфікс “ат” – сульфатна та нітратна.
Якщо ж ви переходите до проміжного
ступеня окислення +4 у сульфуру
та +3 у нітрогену, суфікс змінюється
на ”ит” або “іт”. Вони чергуються.
Уважно!
Не плутати з суфіксом “ид” та ”ід”.
Іще деякі окремі випадки –
це коли той же самий елемент
в одному і тому ж самому ступені
окислення має декілька варіантів кислот.
Наведемо приклади.
Дві кислоти з елементом фосфору:
Аш-Пе-О-три та Аш-три-Пе-О-чотири
мають у собі фосфор в одній і
тій самій ступені окисленні – +5 і +5.
В загальному випадку ми би їх назвали
фосфатними обидві – кислота фосфатна.
Але, оскільки ми маємо їх розрізняти,
то ми додаємо окремі префікси.
В першому випадку – це
метафосфатна, префікс “мета”
і в другому випадку – це –
ортофосфатна, префікс “орто”.
Що ж стосується кислот в органічній
хімії, то вони підпорядковуються
загальним правилам IUPAC, які
ви можете згадати з 9 або 10 класу.
Тепер перейдемо до
властивостей хімічних кислот.
Згадуючи 8 клас, ви, мабуть, згадали,
що кислоти вступають в реакції з металами
і, в принципі, при цьому
вони виділяють деякий газ.
Давайте перевіримо це.
Візьмемо соляну кислоту
або хлоридну Аш-Хлор
і зануримо туди декілька
шматочків металу цинку.
Як ви бачите, з поверхні вашого
металу почали утворюватись бульбашки,
тобто – виділяється деякий газ.
Потім перевіримо, що це за
газ і які в нього властивості,
але можете уважно поспостерігати
за інтенсивністю виділення цього газу.
Якщо візьмемо ту ж є саму кислоту і
інший метал, в даному випадку – це магній.
Він у нас порошкоподібний, хоча
він існує у вигляді цільних шматків.
В принципі, великої різниці немає.
Наливаю невеличку кількість кислоти.
Ви бачите, що інтенсивність
виділення водню в рази більша.
Кислота практично миттєво реагує з цим
порошком. Що змінилось? Змінився метал.
І от для того, щоб визначати – наскільки
інтенсивно метал реагує з кислотами –
для цього існує ряд активності металів.
Якщо ви уважно подивитесь на нього, то
активність металів спадає зліва направо.
Але десь посередині між
металом плюмбумом та купрумом
(свинцем та міддю, відповідно),
ви бачите молекулу Аш-два. Молекула Аш-два
(гідроген) не відповідає – це не метал.
Чому ж вона там знаходиться?
Вона знаходиться там саме
для того, щоб ви могли визначити –
які метали реагують з
кислотами, виділяючи водень,
а які – не реагують з
кислотами, виділяючи водень.
Для цього ми візьмемо шматочок міді –
метал, який знаходиться правіше від водню
в ряду активності металів та перевіримо,
чи буде він хоч якимось
чином взаємодіяти з кислотами.
Мідь занурюємо в пробірку і
додаємо ту ж саму нашу соляну кислоту.
Як ви бачите – жодних бульбашок, окрім
тих, які утворилися при змішуванні, немає.
Але навіть і вони зараз
нічого не утворюють.
Метал не розчиняється – як
лежить на дні, так і лежить.
На відміну від цих двох – як ви бачите,
реакції проходять дуже і дуже активно.
Для того, щоб перевірити, що це – саме
водень, я зібрав його ось в цю кульку.
Кулька достатньо важка.
Але навіть ви зараз можете бачити,
що вона все ж таки трохи левітує,
тому що водень легший за
повітря. Підпалимо його. Лунає вибух.
Як ви бачили, вибух – це
типова класична реакція водню.
Що ж, переходимо саме до
описання тих властивостей
і тих перетворень, які в
нас тільки що відбувались.
Цинк та магній, напишемо
їх у загальному вигляді, - метал
(оскільки вони ще обидва
двовалентні, то це дуже зручно)
- реагують із соляною кислотою.
При цьому утворюється сіль
Метал-Хлор-два і виділяється водень.
Рівняння реакції залишаю вам.
Рівняння ви бачите на екрані.
Спробуйте це вдома
Те, що це водень, ми тільки що
довели тим, що він вибухає на повітрі
Аш-два плюс О-два, при цьому
утворюючи Аш-два-О (воду).
А наша мідь, яка реагувала, мала
прореагувати, але не реагує з Аш-Хлор
не розчиняється в ній, тому
що це неактивний метал.
Це загальні властивості кислот,
вони стосуються усіх кислот одночасно.
Тепер перейдемо до двох окремих
кислот, які мають деякі особливості.
Одна з цих кислот – це нітратна кислота.
В моєму випадку вона
чиста, тобто концентрована.
Давайте перевіримо чи буде взаємодіяти
метал купрум з нітратною кислотою.
Але, оскільки нітратна кислота – це
небезпечна речовина, вдягну рукавички.
Вливаємо азотну кислоту і
занурюємо невеличкий шматок міді.
Як ви бачите: перше –
вона почала розчинятись,
вона забарвлює ваш
розчин у зелений колір.
Це зрозуміло, тому що солі
міді саме зеленого кольору.
Але, якщо ви подивитесь, то на поверхні
починається виділення деякого газу,
який ще й має забарвлення.
В даному випадку такий помаранчево-бурий.
Що це за газ і чому він,
все ж таки, виділяється?
Перше, що ми можемо сказати – це те, що
наша мідь взаємодіє з нітратною кислотою.
Але при цьому, реакція
відбувається іншим чином.
Давайте подумаємо, що
саме сприяє такій реакції.
Для того, щоб зрозуміти – що
саме відбувається в цій реакції,
запишемо формулу
нітратної кислоти Аш-Ен-О-три,
яка складається з двох частин: катіону
та аніону Ен-О-три з мінусом. Що цікаво?
Посередині в склад нітрату аніону
входить нітроген зі ступеню окислення +5.
Але як ми знаємо – ось зараз вже
видно набагато краще колір цього газу.
Він ще називається лисячий хвіст.
Посередині знаходиться
нітроген зі ступеню окислення +5,
але ми знаємо, що нітроген існує
не тільки в таких ступенях окислення,
але і нітроген +4, нітроген +3, нітроген
+2, нітроген 0, а також – нітроген -3.
Тобто, у нас є цілий ряд
варіантів ступенів окислення,
в яких може стабільно
існувати наш нітроген.
Що ж конкретно відбувається
на поверхні цього металу?
Метал – це та сполука, яка
може віддавати електрони.
В нашому випадку нітроген
може приймати ці електрони ззовні
і, відповідно, відновлюватись.
Що саме відбувається?
Мідь, яка реагує з нітратною кислотою,
віддає свої електрони до нітрогену,
при цьому – сама перетворюється на
двовалентну мідь Купрум-Ен-О-три-двічі.
Бурий газ, який виділяється –
це Ен-О-два і утворюється вода.
Раджу вам врівнювати це рівняння
за допомогою електронного балансу.
Тепер дивіться – це була
концентрована азотна кислота.
Зробимо теж саме, але візьмемо
не концентровану азотну кислоту,
а розведену азотну
кислоту, а метал змінимо на цинк.
Для того, щоб зробити розведену азотну
кислоту, я відберу 5 мл цієї кислоти
та розведу деякою кількістю води
– приблизно щоб вона була 10%.
Тобто, мені потрібно 45 мл води.
Доводжу її до 50 мл.
Занурюємо туди цинк.
Як ви бачите, цинк починає
реагувати, але при цьому
жодного виділення бурого
газу не спостерігається,
хоча якісь бульбашки виділяються.
Давайте розберемось: що
це можуть бути за бульбашки
і від чого залежать наші продукти.
По-перше, порівняємо, що ми змінили.
Ми зменшили концентрацію
нітратної кислоти.
Тепер її стало менше, хай буде
на один літр або на один кубик.
І, по-друге, ми змінили мідь на
більш активний метал – на цинк.
Тобто, електрони віддаються
активніше і при цьому,
якщо вони приймаються Ен-О-три з
мінусом, то вона може його перетворити
на більш глибоко
відновлену формулу нітрогену.
Наприклад, одна з них
це – нітроген +2, нітроген 0.
Давайте запишемо що ж відбувається
в даному конкретному випадку.
Цинк з азотною кислотою може
настільки сильно відновити наш нітроген,
що при цьому виділиться чистий
азот, в якого ступінь окислення 0.
Хоча, коли я записую цю реакцію, це не
значить, що там не виділяється газ Ен-О,
або, наприклад, взагалі
може утворитись Ен-Аш-три,
який миттєво з азотною
кислотою перетворюється на сіль
Ен-Аш-читири-Ен-О-три.
Тобто, все залежить від умов.
Якщо ви мене спитаєте –
які саме продукти я можу,
в залежності від типу металів і
від концентрації кислоти, знайти –
то їх перелік буде наступним:
Ен-О-два, Ен-О, Ен-два, а
також Ен-Аш-чотири та його сіль.
Скоріше за все – це буде
Ен-Аш-читири-Ен-О-три,
якщо немає жодних інших аніонів.
Чому не виділяється Аш-два?
Адже здається у нас є Н+.
Якщо ми його розведемо, той же самий цинк
не забороняв нам
виділяти Аш-два в Аш-Хлор.
Добре – мідь його не виділяє,
але цинк же міг його виділяти.
Справа в тому, пояснення
тут достатньо просте,
що як тільки у вас виділяється Аш-2,
а він виділяється на поверхні металу:
по-перше, скоріше за все він
виділяється у вигляді атомарного водню
і тільки потім перетворюється на Аш-два.
Він миттєво відновлює нашу
кислоту до інших проміжних формул.
Наприклад, до Аш-Ен-О-два плюс Аш-два-О,
або ж до такої кислоти,
яка існує тільки у розчинах:
Аш-Ен-О плюс Аш-два-О і так далі
можемо відновлювати їх ще глибше.
Тобто, водень, який може і
виділяється в якийсь момент часу,
практично миттєво з нашою азотною
кислотою перетворює на проміжні сполуки.
В тому числі і на ті сполуки,
які потім виділяються,
тому що Аш-Ен-О-два може
розкладатись на Ен-О-два, Ен-О і воду.
Які особливості зустрічаються
у сірчаної кислоти?
Сірчана кислота чимось
схожа до нітратної кислоти,
оскільки там теж присутній
елемент сульфур в даному випадку,
У вищій ступені окислення – сульфур +6,
який може через проміжні ступені
окислювання відновлюватись до сульфуру +4,
сульфур 0, а також сульфур -2.
Відповідно, все залежить від
того, наскільки активний ваш метал.
Якщо ваш метал достатньо
пасивний, наприклад, купрум,
то він буде реагувати з сірчаною кислотою
аналогічно до реакції
з нітратною кислотою –
буде утворюватись Купрум-Ес-О-чотири
плюс Ес-О-два плюс Аш-два-О.
Єдина примітка – сірчана кислота веде себе
так тільки тоді, коли вона концентрована.
Як тільки вона стає розведеною, вона
себе веде як будь-яка звичайна кислота
Тобто, якщо взяти розведену
кислоту Аш-два-Ес-О-чотири
і занурити в неї той же самий метал
цинк або магній – не принципово що,
то вона буде реагувати з
ним як і кислота Аш-Хлор.
Може трошки пасивніше, тому
що тут невисока концентрація.
Але, як ви бачите, мікро бульбашки з
поверхні цинку вже починають підійматись.
Залишаємо.
Тобто, ви бачите, що в більшості випадків
кислоти, при взаємодії з металами,
виявляють одні і ті ж самі
властивості за виключенням
буквально двох кислот та
деяких конкретних ситуацій.
Повертаючись до ще двох
особливостей, але це, скоріше, стосується
не металів, а кислот, в тому
числі і металів – це залізо і алюміній.
Ми покажемо це на прикладі алюмінію.
Якщо взяти концентровану азотну
кислоту і занурити туди алюміній…
Нагадую, що алюміній в ряду
активності набагато лівіше
ніж той же самий купрум
і навіть лівіше ніж цинк.
Тобто, ми мали б очікувати
розчинення. Перевіряємо.
Як ви бачите, жодної активності не
відбувається, алюміній не розчиняється.
Або перевіримо – може
алюміній якийсь неправильний.
Занурюємо його в нашу соляну кислоту.
Заберемо звідти цинк,
щоб він нам не заважав.
Як ви бачите, хоч і не так активно,
але бульбашки на поверхні
алюмінію, все ж таки, з’являються.
Тобто, алюміній, не дивлячись на
те, що він активний метал… ось вони.
Внизу на дроті з’явились бульбашки.
Що ж таке відбувається з
алюмінієм в азотній кислоті,
що він потім перестає розчинятися?
Насправді – на поверхні алюміній
не знаходиться у чистовому вигляді.
Він настільки активний метал, що
він утворює оксид Алюміній-два-О-три –
ось ця оксидна плівка. Її не так легко
розчинити, Аш-Хлор з цим справляється.
І Аш-Хлор потроху розчиняє наш
алюміній, при цьому виділяючи водень.
Як тільки ви занурюєте
алюміній у нітратну кислоту,
ця оксидна плівка навпаки – вона не
руйнується, а ще більше утворюється.
Поверхня вашого алюмінію пасивується.
Те ж саме відбувається і з залізом.
Саме тому такий важливий для
хімічної промисловості продукт,
як нітратну кислоту, а
також сірчану, до речі,
можна перевозити в алюмінієвих пляшках,
або в алюмінієвих якихось футлярах.
Те ж саме відбувається і з залізом.
Воно пасивується і у
концентрованій сірчаній кислоті,
і у концентрованій нітратній кислоті.
І, наприклад, якщо ви візьмете алюміній,
який тільки що розчинявся
у соляній кислоті,
хоч і не так активно
через алюмінієву плівку
і після пасивації у нітратній
кислоті занурите в соляну –
ви побачите, що тут в принципі
будь-яких бульбашок не утворюється.
Ось це неутворення
бульбашок і відповідає за те,
що у нас з’явилась
пасивація нашого алюмінію.
Тепер він став дуже хімічно інертним.
Тобто, таким чином він стає
схожим взагалі на шляхетні метали:
золото, або платина, або паладій,
які взагалі не розчиняються у більшості
кислот, в тому числі і в нітратній,
в тому числі і в сірчаній концентрованій.
Звичайно, ви знаєте, що деякі кислоти
при потраплянні всередину
організму викликають, наприклад,
жгуче пекло, розчиняють,
навіть деякі тканини.
А деякі кислоти ми
навіть приймаємо з їжею –
та ж лимонна кислота, оцтова
кислота, аскорбінова кислота.
Або, коли ви п’єте
будь-яку газовану воду –
ви п’єте буквально карбонатну
кислоту в деякій концентрації.
Звичайно, ми можемо сказати,
що кислоти розрізняються.
За чим же вони розрізняються?
Кислоти розрізняються за своєю силою.
Є сильні кислоти – це ті кислоти,
які дуже гарно дисоціюють,
або практично повністю розпадаються
на відповідний катіон і аніон.
Типовий приклад: Аш-Ен-О-три –
нітратна кислота або соляна кислота.
Є деякі кислоти слабкі.
Типовий приклад слабкої кислоти –
це оцтова кислота Це-Аш-три-Це-О-О-Аш,
яка дисоціює на ацетат йон і Н+.
Але дисоціює достатньо слабко,
саме тому – реакція рівноважна
і іноді вона зміщена
саме в лівий бік цієї реакції.
Є кислоти середньої сили,
але це дуже таки уявна градація.
За що скоріше вона може відповідати?
Бо якщо ви візьмете
ту ж саму оцтову кислоту
і багато-багато разів її розведете, в
кінці кінців вона повністю продисоціює.
Кислоти можна розділити
на сильні і слабкі.
Десь між ними, в залежності від того,
наскільки зміщена наша ця рівновага,
знаходяться кислоти середньої сили.
Наприклад, типова
кислота середньої сили –
це мурашина кислота,
яку ви вивчали в 10 класі.
Більш слабкі кислоти не
витісняють сильні кислоти.
Але навпаки – сильні кислоти
витісняють більш слабкі кислоти.
Саме тому, наприклад, якщо
ви візьмете сіль слабкої кислоти,
в даному випадку – це карбонат кальцію
або це те, з чого складається крейда.
І додати до цього карбонату
кальцію більш сильну кислоту,
можна оцтову взяти, можна
взяти, наприклад, соляну.
Ми побачимо активне виділення
газу із спіненням. Чому саме?
Тому що Аш-Хлор – це сильна кислота.
При взаємодії з карбонатом
кальцію Кальцій-Це-О-три,
вона витісняє більш
слабку карбонатну кислоту,
утворює при цьому
Кальцій-Хлор-два і Аш-два-Це-О-три.
Оскільки Аш-два-Це-О-три
– це нестабільна кислота,
вона розкладається на
Це-О-два – вуглекислий газ і воду,
виділення вуглекислого газу ви і
спостерігали у вигляді бульбашок.
Ось вони ще виділяються.
Де ж ви зустрічаєтесь з
кислотами, окрім якихось, наприклад,
як то лимонна кислота,
чи як то оцтова кислота?
Насправді ви і самі складаєтесь
в значній мірі з кислот,
оскільки білки побудовані з
маленьких молекул амінокислот.
Але ми розглянемо ще один
аспект взаємодії з кислотами.
Є таке кліматичне явище,
яке називається кислотні дощі.
Вони іноді випадають, а також
пошкоджують деякі архітектурні пам’ятки.
Наприклад, в Греції є велика
кількість пам’яток, зроблених з мармуру,
які поїли кислотні дощі. Що саме
відбувається і що таке кислотні дощі?
Справа в тому, що наша атмосфера
складається з величезної кількості газів.
Але значну її частину, приблизно 78%
складає такий газ як азот – Ен-два.
Регулярно у нас відбуваються якісь
грози або, наприклад, може бути розряд
між трамваєм та його лініями –
і тоді азот вступає в реакцію з
відповідним киснем, утворюючи газ Ен-О.
Реакція рівноважна, але вона
відбувається при електричному розряді.
Ен-О миттєво вступає в реакцію з
киснем, утворюючи газ Ен-О-два –
газ бурого кольору, який ви
спостерігали сьогодні на уроці.
Ен-О-два при взаємодії з водою
виявляє кислотні властивості.
Він утворює одночасно дві кислоти:
Аш-Ен-О-два і Аш-Ен-О-три,
хоча в присутності кисню
Аш-Ен-О-два теж
перетворюється у Аш-Ен-О-три.
Таким чином, якщо у вас відбувається
гроза і при цьому існують блискавки,
вони можуть призвести до появи
такої кислоти як Аш-Ен-О-три.
А насправді, якщо у вас в
атмосфері ще й присутні викиди,
наприклад, сполук сульфуру Ес-О-два,
які дуже часто присутні у викидах
з вугільних електростанцій, вони
можуть взаємодіяти з тим газом Ен-О-два,
при цьому утворюючи оксид
вищого ступеня окислення сульфуру
Ес-О-три і Ен-О, який
потім при взаємодії з водою
утворює сильну сірчану
кислоту Аш-два-Ес-О-чотири.
Саме тому дуже важливо контролювати
викиди багатьох заводів, фабрик
та вугільних електростанцій
для того, щоб потім
в кліматичних явищах не
з’являлись кислотні дощі.
На сьогодні все.
Дякую за увагу!